well the latest wave of emails from
Anthony Weiner member him he's in prison
now and his former wife Huma habit II
and shared laptop have come out they've
exposed five more classified messages
that should not legally have been there
we now know of 18 of those that were on
the laptop tom Fitton is the president
Judicial Watch which secured the release
of these emails and he joins us tonight
with an update Tom how hard was it to
get these oh it only took two years
federal lawsuit the FBI found these
records last year back in October when
James Comey famously announced that at a
press conference there were other
documents on the Weiner laptop these
documents the personal property of Huma
Abedin and Anthony Weiner
or were they government property which
belongs to us yeah they were FBI right
the FBI determined there were government
records and they turned over to the
State Department who took forever why'd
you have to wait two years and sue to
get them well because we found out about
Clinton's email server back in 2015 we
knew ulama badeen had an email account
on that server we asked for her emails
and they eventually found some of more
dish additional emails on the Weiner
laptop that were government records and
again these are classified records that
James Comey and his colleagues at the
FBI knew were on the Weiner laptop but
they didn't think serious enough to
pursue criminal charges against Abidine
or Clinton for allowing this egregious
abuse of their trust that the American
people placed in them in terms of secure
and classified information to be abused
so since you've been in Washington a
long time in follow cases like this for
a long time
give us some perspective if you had the
this many classified documents on your
laptop what would the consequences be
well you'd be you'd lose your security
clearance almost initially and you'd be
subject to a criminal investigation and
perhaps a prosecution and it wasn't just
below level classified materials that
were found in the Clinton email server
but there were highly top-secret
documents of the most secure of the most
secure type and it would have resulted
in criminal prosecution I guarantee you
if you were anyone else but the
Democratic nominee for the president you
know there are four and a half billion
people last I checked with security
clearances
they all know this is a scam the way
that Hillary Clinton and Abidine have
been protected and this is why it's
interesting to see the Justice
Department as reported today is actually
re looking at this issue finally so the
pressures working Tucker the Justice
Department is going to go back and ask
at least some questions about how this
the Comey lynch Justice Department and
FBI handled this last year about the
classified information how that was
handled a decision not to prosecute and
things like that and it's well past time
that that take place so a system that
crushes ordinary people protects the
powerful and well-connected that's right
and right now we are fighting this
Justice Department the State Department
the Director of National Intelligence
over whether they're even going to do a
damage assessment over having classified
material as I say on the internet
equivalent of a public park bench
unbelievable thank you tom Fitton won't
is he